the Joe Rogan experience it's like
people don't remember Bill Gates the old
Bill Gates right people see Bill Gates
now I see Bill Gates now and I see a guy
was wearing an outfit here's an outfit
it's like he's got a like spider-man
like it puts on a spider-man this is my
really nice rich guy thing got a sweater
[ __ ] it's a hundred degrees outside why
you got that sweater with a shirt
underneath it it's secretly ventilated
and yeah did you ever have a t-shirt on
does Bill Gates a movie show I heard he
had a house where when you walk into a
room it recognizes like how you like the
temperature like you're a band yes Penn
yeah it would change the temperature it
would make coffee it that you like and I
was like my I was seeing when I heard
about there's nothing I wish I had that
cuz that's how the girl in or was over
[Laughter]
change the settings on you changes the
artwork flips over right right but I
mean yeah he called visto he called Iowa
we weren't ready to abandon make like
years ago 15 2015 yeah yes well he set
it up he's the mastermind I mean one of
the Incredibles like the bad guy in
English I'm just confused by his outfit
cuz it's like he's dressing up like mr.
Rogers on purpose he wants you to think
of him in a different way he's a savage
man most ruthless [ __ ] when he
was running Microsoft
that's why Microsoft got so you right
they would take no prisoners businessmen
yes take no prisoners he's but he's
pretending like he's you know I kind of
loved that [ __ ] though like when people
cuz you just have to know how to look
for it right yeah like like I don't
trust anybody that doesn't cuss on stage
you know like come on man that's a
button-up tee shirt with a collar
everything has a collar though but
that's a long time ago that looks like
about 15 years old
it's a nice career though you dad look
at that crew is like looters like the
Forrest Gump
factor after me where's that connected
like a lot of money and use like I'll
take it
yeah amazing
[Applause]